all right this is the moment you've all
been waiting for this
is jeopardy warm-up we get to see which
of our contestants
we grabbed three of them off the street
we've got brian loftus
denise valdez and ted florendo in town
let's see what happens
yeah it is dinner time you get 15
seconds to answer this question and here
is our
yeah bragging rights by the way if you
win this thing here it is right here you
go in 1996 this major league baseball
team opened its season
with its first six games right here in
las vegas you have 15 seconds
go devin my cameraman what's the answer
okay we're counting down we are
absolutely counting
down aren't we so what happens this has
only happened twice by the way in the
history of baseball really
where a major league baseball team opens
in a minor league ballpark
time is up let's go to denise valdez as
she flips she hides her face
and flips her because this one's so easy
if you don't get it
you got it denise got it yes indeed
let's roll the video
as the rest of us go ahead brian go
ahead by the way denise has got good
jumping today ryan has
dinner time who are the a's brian gets
it also this is video from 1996 the game
ted florento what did you have oh [ __ ]
let's go
let's see i thought it was too easy
dodgers well i knew two of you would get
it so yeah it was 1996.
by the way the dodgers were the first
back in the 50s they were the first
major league baseball team
to play in a minor league ballpark but
so the oakland come here as well let's
run that video once again denise got it
brian got it it is dinner time roll the
video
1996 the open aids came here and played
the toronto blue jays for three games
then they played the detroit tigers for
three games
while the oakland alameda coliseum was
getting renovated and fixed because of
the loss
or the now i see las vegas writers the
oakland raiders they were fixing the
the mount davis they call it there that
bulk at the stadium there in oakland so
because of the raiders oakland came here
once again so anyway
ted you know what good job the answer
brian good job denise good job
ted no can we can we say one thing you
know what chris loves saying he loves
saying roll that video
like no that's really what i love what
love island
yes